Explorers opened up the world all around, these fearless souls.
They succeeded in doing well in all hemispheres.
Their great audacity made us an offering of the Earth.
Yes, these knights, I tell you, have never wavered, the explorers have never weakened.
Nothing can stop them, neither wind nor storm.
These men of heart, no, their canvas is nothing but a beautiful sky of stars.
The dream of advancing is crazy and without worrying about jealousy.
It sails forward.
The explorers on the oceans, their navigators bravely memorized them.
In fact, brave the storms, their little black shells were really no match.
And on the raging waves, their temerity was clearly demonstrated.
The explorers always reveal new things to us with breath.
Reject fear.
Refuse all fear of adventures.
Ready to give back this world and offer the sun to.
Souls.
Amigo.
Amigur, huh?
But excuse me, Captain, but it's the parrot.
It's the parrot who sent me this shoe, huh?
No, but it's him who, well no, that's me.
We're not making any progress.
Yes, since we left, you promised to tell me how you, the son of a notary, became a scholar
and a navigator.
So, I'm listening to you since there's nothing else to do but wait for the wind to pick up.
Come on, maybe this is the time.
No, I'll do it.
But it's a long story, you know.
Maybe a love story gone wrong.
It happened in Florence a long time ago.
Leonardo da Vinci.
Maybe you should watch where you put your feet.
My bad, Amerigov Spucci.
And what's up with you, Leonardo?
I paint.
My father enrolled me in Velocchio's studio.
Velocchio?
Well, he's a great painter.
You're lucky.
And you?
I'm studying.
My uncle Giorgio is teaching me Latin, mathematics, astronomy, history, philosophy.
You're lucky too.
You're going to become a scholar.
I'd like that too.
To study mathematics and Latin.
See you soon, Amerigo.
Bye.
We'll start with mathematics.
As you know, I've taught you everything I know.
Paolo Canelloli, the great geographer, will share his new ideas with you.
Everyone now knows that you can get to Asia by going around Africa,
but I'm sure that you can also reach Asia in much less time by sailing west.
But then, the Earth would be smaller than we think.
It's possible.
I sent my map to a Genoese sailor who wants to attempt this voyage.
His name is Cotan.
Ballone.
Colon.
Yes, that's it, Christopher Columbus.
Thanks to Archimedes' science, Clid's mathematics, and to Leem's geography,
the stars in the sky no longer hold any secrets for me.
Simonetta, all this is...
Really very interesting, Cousin Amarigo.
And what are you going to do with all this knowledge,
as well as Plato's philosophy that you spoke to me about at length last time?
I don't know yet, Simona.
I would like to travel, to discover the world.
What I do know is that one day I will be famous.
How pretty you are, Cousin Simonetta.
What a marvel.
Tell me, sir. I find you very impertinent. Forgive me, but I am astounded. The oval of that face,
the copper of her hair, that slender figure, that angelic gaze. How dare you? Come on, sir.
Oh, forgive me, but you see, I am a painter. My name is Botticelli.
The famous Botticelli?
Yes, famous. Well anyway, yes, Sandro Botticelli. I am currently preparing a large painting,
The Birth of Venus. I was dreaming of finding a model. And you, are you?
Mr. Bottice Shelley, do you really think so?
No, yes, I am certain of it.
If you agree, you see, my painting, my painting, will be the rebirth of life.
The freshness, the symbol of pure love emerging from the waters to conquer the world.
And I don't think anyone has come forward yet to express that.
And with your face like a Madonna, or rather a saint,
there is no doubt that you will be able to give my inspiration a boost or rather a flight of fancy.
I tried my hand at painting, but I really wasn't.
Good at it.
Well, you don't eat, Marigo.
Father, I haven't done anything with my life yet and I'm going to be 30.
Listen, I know the Medici well.
Do you want me to find you a place in their bank?
Well, you see, Uncle Giorgio, people around me are doing wonderful things.
Leonardo became a great painter, as did Botticelli.
The young Maievil, he too, made a name for himself through politics.
Pictola Miranda, who is 10 years younger than me, that's already something.
I haven't done anything.
No one will ever remember my name.
Who knows, Amarigo, the world is in turmoil at the end of this century.
There are still so many things to do, to discover.
Oh, I've had enough of this stupid work.
Amarigo, you have a visitor, His Excellency Laurentiis.
Listen, Amarigo, you are a good banker but you are bored here.
Do you want to go to Seville in Spain?
We have some interesting business there.
There you go, I am.
Ready, Your Excellency.
Welcome to Seville.
You are at Mago Vespierre of Florence. How do you know, Mr. Berardi? Here we are not used to
wearing clothes either. The Spanish-like dark colors. You've come to the right place. I need
help equipping a large expedition. A certain Christopher Columbus went to the Indies,
but he sailed west. Do you realize when he went west? H. Christopher Columbus. I've heard that
name before. And on August 3, 1492, Christopher Columbus left Spain to head west. His voyage may
have lasted a year, but he reached the Indies. The Indies, you say? Are you sure he really went
to the Indies? Of course. Otherwise, where would these Indians come from? However, I was told that
the Indians wore turbans on their heads and sumptuous clothing. Mr. Berardi, I intend to
leave again in a few months with a larger number of ships. Can you join me in Cadiz where I will
prepare my new expedition? Admiral, so do we. Perfect. We must hurry. Mr. Berardi, my new
expedition will leave in three months. This time, it will include 17 ships, more than 1,000 men,
and livestock. I want 80 cannons, plus 30 barrels of gunpowder, 40 cows, bulls, 100 horses, and as
many goats and poor people. Will that be all? And also 32 barrels of wine, 20 bags of wheat seed,
and that's an order. Let's get to work. Hey, Colonel there's no mistake, your graceful majesty.
we have indeed reached china listen christopher columbus was a good sailor but he knew nothing
about geography to find your bearings you first have to take measurements with an astrologer so
do you think columbus did yes and by the way i'm going to prove it and discover the true route to
the indies you know the rest as well as i do since we experienced it together go on anyway
it will remind us of how we found that one and other memories i have received your communications
Lord Vespucci
This is the land that Columbus discovered
We must explore it, describe it, make a map of it and discover others
Captain Alonso de Horeta, you will take command of a ship
Amigo Vespucci, you will draw up precise maps for us
. Christopher Columbus is
In Hispaniola to the northwest
We will head southwest
Look, we must be at the mouth of a large river
Tonight, I will go ashore like this
I will take the latitude
Only a large continent can give
birth to such a large river. It looks like Venice. Well, we will call this place Venesette or
Venezuela in Spanish. And finally, I don't understand. Big ships make small boats. It's
magic. We are in danger. I don't understand that. And yet we had done nothing to them.
They were afraid of us. We're going to continue south. Have to be careful, yes, but also believe
in their goodwill. Well, let's go. It's true that they seem rather welcoming. He even brings us
food. Those are pearls. Oh wow. There must be a mine. Go ahead. Ask him. Gold. I need some more.
Where does this gold come from? I want more. Where is the gold? Question mark. It's not enough. It's
taking too long to get some later. I'm sure he's at a mine. But he doesn't want to give it to us.
Let's grab him. Go on. Take it easy or else. So where is this mine? Can. Stop him. Started it. Oh
no it's you you'll see what you're going to see hair not the hair where did the savage go maybe
better to go back no they were friendly though what happened over there no one can live in there
let's go see but let's be careful oh delicious oh i'll take some for my collection no oh how
wonderful this is neither china nor india but a new world a mushroom but what is this oh look
this must be good it's strong what am i fed up with i'm going home i don't like these countries
amerigo come and see this what kind of nose is that amerigo i want one i need one amerigo
amayo amayo if this continues like this you'll become famous we should go back or we'll get lost
dot come on we've seen enough oh what a strange animal it's for my collection hey let go of animal
I go. Hurry up. This really isn't the time to hang around. This one, if you want it for your
collection, well, you can go get it yourself. Oh, my collection. My collection. You'll find other
opportunities. I'm going to calculate the position of this river. Ah, the North Star. It's really low.
Let's see. So, 10 degrees north. We're a few hundred miles from the equator. This isn't an
island, Alonzo. This is a new world. And do you remember what you told me? Do you remember? Yes,
it may be a new world, but it's not paradise. And all that to get here. We're going to run out of
water soon. I'm going to get some sleep. Call me if there's ever a cold wind. You see, children,
so that you understand better, it was at this place near Lorinoc that Vespucci first set foot
on the American continent. He's at the mouth of the Amazon. And all these strange animals,
all these plants that Vespucci claims to have discovered, were really unknown.
In Europe? No. Ah, do you know that in Europe, they didn't know about tomatoes, potatoes,
corn, peanuts, sunflowers, manioc, cotton, pepper, pineapple, chocolate. Chocolate either.
No, at least cocoa, which is used to make chocolate and rubber. Ouch. Oh, there are so
many things I'm forgetting. Oh yes. Well, avocados, avocados, tobacco, we could have thought of that
one, vanilla, and turkey of course. How? Could I forget turkey? And what happened to our friends
who we left stranded without wind? The wind will pick up eventually. You'll see. What? What is it?
Can't you hear? We're going to have a bad storm, look. And then stop waving that shoe. But look,
I think it's going to be tough. It's better that than dead. Calm. Full sail. Full sail.
Our almighty father, protect us from the raging elements. The parrot has disappeared. Yes,
we're lucky to still be alive. There's not a drop of water left. Plus, the flower is soaked.
We're near land. We'll restock. It's the sails. Amerigo. Amerigo. You. They're going to end up
sinking us, firing cannons. They look like snakes with legs. They're reptiles. But what a shell.
These creatures are really ferocious. In any case, they're not bad. They look a bit like
chickens. I think we're at the equator. Let's head west. A man overboard. Full speed ahead to
Tribor. Oh, oh, the water. It's sweet. And it's even good to drink. Come on, Giovanni. What are
you talking about? Taste it, you'll see. Huh? But he's right. It's not salty at all. And yet
there's no land in sight. So it must be a gigantic river. In any case, incredible. Let's take on
water we're running out here sails head west brisande watch out sandbar and there you have it
exactly on which ones tomorrow we're going up the flower this way the devil is the devil pigs
a good meal in prospect but what's gotten into you alonzo horror that nose did you see that nose
no come on you shouldn't be afraid of little creatures alonzo he was getting rid of some
ants for you. You shouldn't be afraid of little creatures in Mago. They're heading towards our
village. I don't think they're friends. We mustn't. Let them get close. We'll kill them. Why? Maybe
they're not bad. I don't think they're men. Come on. Let's kill them. That way, we can eat them.
No, let's see first. If we have to kill them, we'll do it when the time comes. I agree. We'll
go and hide. We come from far away. We come from the east where the sun rises. We would like to be
your friends. In 1501, Vespi, this time alone without Alonso Retta, is at the head of three
caravels and he is going to set off on a new voyage. This one will be on behalf of Manuel I
of Portugal. He will draw up plans to define precise latitudes and longitudes. Then he will
write a book. I lived through all these adventures and I knew then that we were indeed in the
presence of a new world. And a few years later in the EVU at Chano Luz, one of the first map
printers. Stop, stop, we have to change everything, huh? What? Tall as maps, my brothers,
Val say Muller. Yes, we have to. It's capped, let's see, it's historical. Brother Martin,
you don't understand. According to Ptolemy, there are only three continents, Africa, Asia,
and Europe. But there is a fourth one that a great traveler named Amerigo Vespucci describes
in detail here. A fourth continent, do you see that? And what is your new continent called?
Well, well, it doesn't have a name, but we could call it Vespucia.
Europa, Asia, Africa.
Vespia, oh no, Martin, no, that sounds a bit miserable.
Vespa, so, Amaitza, oh yes, that's better.
Europa, Asia, Africa, Amaitza, oh yeah, yeah, much better.
Not for, Ametza.
And yes, that's more or less how the new continent will receive the name that you all know.
America.
Explorers discovered the world, made the Earth round.
Innovators will still find ways to trace and then offer them to souls as one offers a beautiful woman to you.
To us, to me, I.
Ah.